in October 2018 a wave flooded the
entire school courtyard and carried away
all the walls that were here after this
the yard was covered with the layer of
sedimentary mud and unfortunately six
months later in April we unexpectedly
found out that the level of arsenic was
abnormally high then a team from the
geological research office conducted an
independent examination and said that
now despite the conclusion of the
previous team there are no more traces
of arsenic
on occasion oh gosh we were worried day
and night our boy had very strong
symptoms when the results were giving to
us at the hospital the doctors told us
the symptoms were related to the levels
of arsenic we are struck by the deafness
of the authorities all the doses simply
swept under the carpet
while there's more and more obvious
evidence that there was a natural
sanitary problem my son got arsenic
poisoning as cool and in the Vale of or
BL where everyone was at risk of
airborne infection and especially my son
because he suffered from the effects of
the flooding in schoolyard
you